today with
righteous rage we're going to cancel
glamour magazine glamour's website
recently featured a story with a
headline that you
already know is going to be a problem
because it contains the word empowering
it also contains the word normalize
which is even more problematic so
putting it all together the headline
declares
this empowering instagram photo to
normalize facial hair for anyone who's
grown up believing
it's uh something to be ashamed of just
went viral
now the article reads because you need
to hear this very important news
it says whether you remove yours with
waxing shaving or sugaring
sugaring what the hell is that or
embrace it in all its glory
what you do with your body hair is
totally your choice we were all born
with it and it's our right to show it
off as we damn well please which is why
we have a serious amount of time for
this photo doing the rounds on instagram
joanna j kenny a 31 year old british
esthetician
took to instagram to share a close-up
snap of her upper lip hair in all its
glory
gross upper lip hair in all its glory
alongside the most empowering caption
for all of my dark-haired friends i'm
wearing my new
lipstick and blue mascara to remind you
all that facial hair is
normal she captioned the picture of her
lip joanna explains that she first
started
noticing upper lip hair in general
facial fuzz when she was a teen
quite rightly the skin care guru
explains that like acne pores lines and
wrinkles
facial hair is airbrushed from most
forms of media which she says
is most people's point of reference to
determine what is normal
so this is me normalizing facial hair
for anyone who's grown up believing it's
something to be ashamed of
she signs off obviously she amassed
plenty of supportive comments from her
followers with people thinking
thanking her for sharing the unfiltered
post and they were then informed that
this is not the first time this woman
has posted to celebrate facial hair on
women
the article says that she recently
shared a list of all the reasons why her
facial hair
makes her beautiful and it's so
empowering
i'm not going to read the list because
frankly i'm too repulsed at this point
to do that
we're going to completely also leave to
the side the issue that the left really
can't normalize bearded women at this
point as they've already made it clear
that bearded women are probably men
anyway i mean they expanded gender roles
until the whole thing snapped back like
a rubber band
and is now more constricted than ever so
now we must suspect at least according
to modern logic that any woman who wants
to grow a beard
is probably actually a man trapped in a
woman's body but as i said we'll ignore
that logistical complication for now
what about this idea um that it's
beautiful and should be normalized
for women to grow facial hair
my short answer to that is no gross stop
my longer answer is seriously disgusting
what are you doing
my even longer answer is that there's a
reason why to my knowledge
no culture has ever embraced female
facial hair as
the pinnacle of feminine beauty go back
even to the ancient egyptians
and women were shaving and removing hair
by whatever primitive means were
available to them
my understanding is that they would
attach jellyfish to their faces
and singe it off and when i say that was
my understanding i mean that i made it
up
but in any case the point is women have
always removed
that kind of unsightly hair why
well there's a reason why facial hair on
men
is considered attractive while facial
hair on women is not and this is an
important point because we hear all
about the beauty standards and it's
supposed to all be arbitrary
it's not arbitrary much of the time
so what's the difference well namely
that facial hair is largely a product of
testosterone
women are biologically inclined to
pursue men with higher levels of
testosterone some of this biological
conditioning may be under siege in
recent years as some women these days
gravitate towards more
sort of androgynous effeminate types you
know the scrawny sexless hairless
gumbies who look like voldemort if he
grew a nose and joined a boy band
those guys exist and there are women who
for whatever reason find them appealing
but for the most part
even now women whether they're conscious
of it or not will prefer men
who give off signs of virility and
strength
on the other hand men again with some
notable exceptions
are not looking for the same sorts of
things in a woman if a man wanted a
woman who was like a man
he'd be gay if he isn't gay then he
wants a woman who's a woman
and on women from a man's perspective
facial hair does not signal desirable
things as
as it does on men for women instead it
signals
poor hygiene and a woman who doesn't
care about her appearance and doesn't
take care of her appearance
of course a woman is free to present
that way if she wants
but she can't be offended when men are
repulsed
because we're told sexual orientation
right is it's not changeable it's
immutable so as heterosexual men we want
what we want and uh we can't help it
and we don't want to be tickled by a
woman's mustache when we go in for the
kiss that's just
that's not what we want that's not our
sexual orientation
is it possible to change all of this i
mean could you over time
condition men to find hairy unkempt
slovenly women attractive
could you condition them even to prefer
that sort of presentation
is this all a matter of arbitrary social
constructs that can be changed
is beauty truly in the eye of the
beholder
well those are all different questions i
suppose and the answer to the lot to the
last question
is no beauty is not just in the eye of
the beholder
there is an objective quality to beauty
like there are things that are
objectively beautiful and things that
are objectively ugly
and if you think that
that an objectively ugly thing is
beautiful it's not just your perspective
you're actually
wrong you have you have the wrong
perspective
we hear so much about shifting beauty
standards
and it's true that superficial
preferences may change over time but the
fact is
that a woman who everyone would find
beautiful today
would be seen as beautiful probably at
any time in history
anywhere in the world there is no time
or place or culture that would shriek in
horror and revulsion
at the sight of marilyn monroe for
example
now there are some places that would
have stoned her to death but that's not
because she was ugly
so beauty is not simply a matter of
subjective preference
there is an objective quality to it that
holds across all cultures
with that said is facial hair a more
superficial matter could you condition
men to like it
could you really succeed in normalizing
it in that way
i think probably not but even if you
could
here's the other question why try
there's nothing wrong with the current
standard just because a standard exists
today and has always existed it doesn't
mean in and of itself that
it should be deconstructed and
deconstructed and overturned
this is what we hear all the time as if
it's self-evident
we're told oh this is a just a social
societal standard we have to get rid of
it
well even if i agree that it's even if
theoretically
it's a basically arbitrary social
standard
why does that mean we should get rid of
it in fact as gk chesterton warned
we should want to know why offense was
put in place before
we tear it down which means the benefit
of the doubt should go to the historical
standard
unless a very good reason can be given
for getting rid of it
and it's a hassle to wax my upper lip is
not a good reason
stop complaining and take care of your
body and your appearance
that is part of your responsibility as a
woman
yes jess says it's the responsibility of
a man to do the same for himself
women have a right to complain when men
allow themselves to become flabby shabby
weak pudgy little things
men can likewise complain when women not
only allow themselves to be unkempt and
unfeminine and gross
but even demand to be celebrated for it
all sides should do their part
this is equality and for women part of
your part is making sure you don't look
like commissioner gordon
when you go out in public and that is
why glamour magazine
and all women attempting to normalize
female facial hair are all today
canceled listen hit that subscribe
button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated